- Les combats se poursuivent
à Sievierodonetsk,
cette grande ville du Donbass.
Moscouonononcentre son offensive
et ses soldats, mais selon
l'armée ukrainienne, une partie
du territoire perdu aux mains
des Russes a été reconquis
"J'ai personnellement entendu
de nombreuses fois que
Sievierodonetsk était occupée,
que l'armée russe l'avait
complètement prise,
explique le gouverneur,
mais ce n'est pas le cas.
Les Russes occupent environ
70 % du territ
Nous avons repris environ 20 %
de celui-ci", dit-il.
Toujours dans le Donbass,
la ville de Soledar est
régulièrement la cible
de tirs russes. Tôt ce matin,
l'appartement de cette dame
a été lourdement endommagé
par le souffle d'un
bombardement.
"Si j'étais restée ici
et que je n'étais pas allée
dans la cuisine, je ne serais
plus en vie", assure-t-elle.
Les batailles acharnées
se poursuivent ailleurs au pays.
Près d'Od a a a a avion
ukrainien transportant des armes
et des munitions a été abattu.
C'est ce que le ministère
russe de la Défense indique
aujourd'hui, faisant le point
sur les dernières opérations.
plplplplplan diplomatique,
Emmanuel Macron est sévèrement
critiqué par Kiev. Il a une
nouvelle fois répété qu'il nefa,
question de préserver les canaux
de communication.
Des propos mal reçus.
Pendant ce temps, l'offensive
russe fait toujours craindre
une crise alimentaire mondiale
L'inquiétude est grandissante,
particulièrement en Afrique,
puisque le continent importe
la forte majorité de
ses céréales d'Ukraine,
mais elles y sont paralysées
en raison de la guerre.
Plus aucun navire ne quitte
le pays. Vladimir Poutine promet
de faciliter le passage
de ces denrées, à condition
que les ports soient déminés
par Kiev.
Ici Aimée Lemieux,
Radio-Can